there's a new scandal with joe biden's
son hunter secret service reportedly got
involved in a bizarre case back in 2018
involving his missing gun hunter's then
girlfriend his brother beau's widow
halle
reportedly lost his weapon after tossing
it in a grocery store trash can because
she quote
thought he was going to kill himself
with it secret service agents allegedly
got involved by trying to obtain the
paperwork
involving the gun sale from the owner of
the store that hunter bought it from
but were unsuccessful and then there's
this
hunter may have broken the law the
report says he answered
no to a question on the background check
form about using drugs
and lying on the form is a felony
so jesse you know this is a very bizarre
story
the gun was tossed into a trash can and
found by a man who was rummaging through
it
and it was across from a high school
could have gotten someone could have
gotten
severely injured if the gun had been
loaded and it was in the trash can that
man found
it um but hunter just seems to leave
things around
like he left the gun in his truck hallie
went and took it to the to the grocery
store left his laptop
at that computer repair shop and it gets
him in trouble
everybody cleans up after him that's the
story of hunter's life
imagine if don jr left a firearm in a
trash bin across from a school and then
the secret service swept in and tried to
cover it up
oh man i can't that's something chris
cuomo would be allowed to report on i
guarantee you
biden's just a chaotic person you know
he's it's
he's he's been like this his whole life
he's been drug addicted
apparently he was suicidal he's reckless
the woman obviously who he was with at
the time was incredibly irresponsible to
just
have a fit and throw the gun at a place
like that and
it but delaware is a small state people
take care of each other there joe's been
there in office for 40 years
his his son was a.g there you know law
enforcement all knows each other the
secret service of course
is going to take care of a former vps
family
haydar the hunter's definitely on their
radar i can guarantee you that so i'm
not surprised
this was covered up and i'm not
surprised the media isn't saying oh
guns danger uh prosecute he'll never get
prosecuted
well juan that's the big question here
right so we're hearing a lot from
joe biden about the need for more gun
safety measures and here we have hunter
biden
lying on an atf background check form
which is a felony
and for normal people if they're
prosecuted it's 10 years in prison at
250
000 fine
well you know the what strikes me about
this story is first i guess it was the
girlfriend
the widow of the brother who threw the
gun not him
uh but you know i think you know the
drugs
the computer yeah i don't know about
that i don't know what exactly is the
i don't know what the technicality is
katie but you shouldn't lie on these
forms i will say this i don't think
there's any cover up
i sure don't think that i think we're
hearing about it we don't know the
details of this story but with the
computer and now with the gun there's no
evidence that anybody
acted to cover up anything with regard
to hunter bite in fact
i think he's written a book his his
troubles are pretty public
greg i mean yeah he loses a laptop here
he loses a gun over there he impregnates
a stripper
the guy can't keep anything in his pants
but you know the the big ques the big
point here and you bring it up
how can you push for gun control when
your own kin
can't control his own gun and here's a
gripe that but this is
what bugs me every family has a hunter
somewhere
could be a cousin but the law isn't that
kind
to a you know a drug-addled sex
addict loser right you don't get this
many breaks
i mean this guy he's not just the black
sheep he's the whole
flock but he his deviance is allowed to
prosper
because his privilege allows him so many
chances
to keep going i mean there's no way a
minority kid
could have gotten away with this resume
of escapades i mean this is truly elite
privilege
and that suicidal mention i you know
i don't know what's going on but that's
generally a lot of times it can be used
as manipulation
when your lifestyle is threatened by a
loved one if they say they want to they
want to take away your drugs or they
want you to
they want you know they're gonna they
want you to seek help you'll go no i'll
kill myself because that will
maintain you know your your uh your kind
of gratuitous lifestyle
so um he's a prime manipulator that's
what he is
hurt a lot of people dana for me yeah
dana for me this this is really about
hunter biden getting away with lying on
a federal
form that would be a felony for any
other person while
joe biden and democrats are preaching
that we need even more laws
and yet we're not willing to prosecute
hunter biden it just seems like an
unfair standard of justice
uh indeed and also this so uh juan says
that we're hearing about it well when
are we hearing about it
we're hearing about it in the spring of
2021
we're not hearing about it um in october
of 2020 um and why is that
and also the u.s secret service um
joe biden wasn't i believe he wasn't
under their protection
at the time in 2018. so were the u.s
secret service acting
on their own were they acting
unofficially
will the biden administration encourage
an inspector general investigation
of this and keep their hands clean of it
uh and and be
transparent about it i think that would
have been a great question at the press
conference today
it would have been dana you're
absolutely right well i hope that there
is some follow-up because there should
be the same legal standard
for lying on background check forms for
everyone else as there is for hunter
biden okay